[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
ça devait être la mère de toutes les
réformes c'est du moins ce que nous
avait promis le président de la
république emmanuel macron de piles
olympe
mais voilà la rentrée de cette réforme
dans l'atmosphère a été terriblement
dégrisante pas une seule et a pas un
seul étage sans un ratage les deux
première année studieuse de monsieur
delevoye pour rien l'avis du conseil
d'état cruel le débat à l'assemblée
nationale
escamoté escamoté parce que l'essentiel
de la discussion sur le financement se
tenait dans une enceinte parallèle et
pour finir un article 49 3 décidé
délibéré au sein d'un conseil des
ministres convoqué en grande pompe pour
discuter de la crise sanitaire
vous allez me dire c'est une habileté
moi je vous réponds c'est une maladresse
monsieur le premier ministre débattre de
la réforme des retraites sans en
connaître le financement c'est se moquer
des français
c'est pourtant c'est pourtant ce que
vous pourriez faire si vous refusez la
main tendue du président du sénat j'ai
entendu moi aussi la question du
président kader il ya quelque chose que
je ne comprends pas vous n'avez cessé de
repousser les dates d'application de la
réforme jusqu'en 2047 alors pourquoi
chipoter vous sûr que quinze jours qui
nous permettrait d'augmenter la qualité
de l'examen du sénat
[Applaudissements]